yes I'm talking about auto doggish but
first just eat a little bit of
background as far as here I am and
what's going on the things so my hats so
professionally I am a data curator at U
of I within the research data service I
help people manage and steward their
data across the research process so
writing documentation finding out where
things are talking very deeply and
personally about file naming conventions
I also leave workshops on those items so
I think about this stuff a lot i'm also
the co-organizer of the champaign-urbana
python users group haiku ah and I teach
Python up with a ton of workshops and I
just got pulled in as a Hail Mary
instructor for the information school
schools python class so now this is my
formal appeal to all of the names of all
of the things you're probably happy I
didn't actually get into all of that so
ah thank you so much for coming and so
the promo uh that this tool attempts to
solve is that documentation is the worst
no one likes it you have to do it but
it's hard you have science to do usually
the night way from an academic
perspective documentation is left to one
of the authoring researchers to deal
with um probably at the very end when
you're like oh man I should make this
data available because open science is
awesome or your publishers requiring it
or something and but yet you have moved
on you have stuff grant stick or keep
they're still going you have a higher
priority things like legitimately higher
priority things to be dealing with then
writing pesky documentation ah people
also come to me thinking that
documentation needs to be this like a
man like massive dissertation level
description of anything and everything
that was done to the data and like if
you want to smash that out on your
keyboard totally awesome love it um but
it's usually what your papers are for
when you're theses and stations are
actually forward to describe so your
documentation doesn't actually need to
be huge document just need to be
something um so all of these factors
come into play and but with the one end
result of documentation usually is not
done
so when we start taking a look further
at documentation and trying to
deconstruct the components of it to
better understand what is it about
documentation it's so rough we can take
a few examples of documentation and ask
ourselves like what what does great
documentation look like but I actually
rephrase this question as what can great
die data documentation look like we're
gonna take a look at a few examples so
I'm gonna with a caveat before we get
started this talk is not about open
science there's a lot of narrative that
comes out of the research data
management world and librarianship that
they owe that you should document and
back up and name things nicely because
you're gonna make it open and people
need to use it and your data means to
live out and open science is the best
and most amazing thing I don't disagree
with any of that but not if you can make
your stuff open or not you still got to
manage your stuff like you've still got
to write papers on it you still got grad
students he might want to use it like
your co-workers might want to use it
eventually you might want to mash it up
so you're like business analyst can use
it like first and foremost you and your
company need to use be able to use your
data which means you need to be able to
find it understand it and like construct
thoughts on it and if you don't know
where it is and if you don't know what
the file name means or how to open up
anymore that information is going to be
lost um so as we say with commenting
your code like you're commenting your
code for your for you in six months and
you document your data for the same
reason you document your data for you
and six months when you're using it
you're like oh man someone just gave me
this awesome data set up up to mash up
and then boom you need do it and hey you
have a whole new paper out of it so this
is valuable stuff to do totally outside
of the open science conversation so um
when I try to explain documentation to
people I like to think of it in terms of
Minimum Viable documentation it needs to
have enough information about the
project methods materials such as the
information is maintainable over
time it's important in an accessible
format because you can't always predict
how people are going to open things and
valuable through those who need it and
this last statement i think is the one
that we should be repeating over and
over and over again if you are not have
you do not need to write your
documentation for 10 year olds you can
write your documentation for your
co-workers for your peers for your buddy
you sits next to you you know you don't
have to go into all of the background
knowledge that someone who's an on
domain expert we'd need to understand it
you can write it for domain experts and
then fill in the gaps when you need to
so the day long didn't read version of
that is something is better than nothing
it doesn't need to be dissertation and
seriously just write something anything
is better than nothing so what are the
basic pieces of documentation so we can
have a code book on one side uh well it
which tries to answer the question of
what are the data values need so if you
look at the tabular data like this
particular cell it has a value of one
what does that mean is that age is that
somehow a height or weight measurement
or temperature or whatever um it
describes what if any coded values mean
within that data so and then you have
the data dictionary which tries to
answer the question of what is this data
file contain and so if you think the
code book talks about the individual
cells the data dictionary generally
talks about the columns within the data
on it describes the questions
measurements etc ah now these things
will often be mashed up depending on
your domain the names can be mixed and
mingled um sometimes I just can all just
be in a single readme.txt it doesn't
need to be separate but the elements and
these questions need to be answered nope
so to look more specifically at talk
edit examples sometimes documentation
can just do all the things and it's gold
standard and it's beautiful it's
wonderful ah I think of icpsr when I
think of that which is a repository for
social science research so this is a
just a screenshot of a PDF they produce
glorious PDFs of documentation on
because they actually have paid staff to
do it so it is not something that like
an authoring faculty has created
so um and it is just left to you can
imagine this is two columns of
documentation ah you see like this top
header you have the variable name and
then colon and then a human name and so
we have person ID and that's pretty
clearly if I saw that in a CSV like yeah
it's the person ID um and then it's nice
to have an expansion app because it r01
underscore ac100 to is not actually
readable to a human um but saying so
this is a question on ever smoked a
cigarette even when our two puffs that's
actually pretty meaningful somebody
skimming through the data file so going
down into the actual sections with our
lovely white space we know how to read
that it has some descriptive information
about what's found inside the columns ah
so at the top line because that's kind
of a unique ID describes some of the
valid cases and how the text actually
appears on the bottom because it's an
actual answering question it has the
question that was read out to the
participant it has some of the missing
codes or the refusal things like that
and then it has a little codes this is
something that like you actually have a
human in front of another human asking
them questions in human language and
they produce an answer to you that you
then code out and that appears in this
column and then because you're in here
and why not you had to explain what
these codes are why not put some
descriptive statistics in place um this
makes it actually super readable for
someone who's trying to assess the value
of this data set ah because you know
like this actually have a meaningful
number of counts for this particular
facet that I care about that's a DOI for
this this is a real piece of
documentation that's do I for this data
so moving away from the gold standard
sometimes you can have a little less but
you can still get along and be just fine
this is another piece of real
documentation from a real data set
located to do I down there so this is
again just a screen shot out of a PDF
that was pretty clearly made in Word
totally fine in this case it's a study
where they actually went another said
where they went on did like really
in-depth interviews and kind of freeform
in-depth interview
with participants and it had a little
bit of coding so they can kind of split
and better understand their data in this
case we're talking one question they
coded what type of lawyer are they were
this is also kind of a UK study so they
use different words than me do um and
you can tell like so 23 of the
participants were solicitors 28 row
barristers and three were a barrister
doing at least some work for the
government I am NOT a lawyer so I don't
necessarily totally understand the
distinctions in here and then below that
they have coded the individual
participant IDs for each so in this case
if I'm a reuse or of this data or if I'm
their peer reviewer I want to know arm
which of the transcript files are
associated with the types of lawyer so I
want all of the transcripts for the
solicitors and I can answer that
question with this and I get a little
bit of descriptive descriptive statistic
well on their like okay you can see it's
kind of reasonably evenly spaced split
sometimes these documentation files can
also be machine readable this isn't a
snippet of against some real
documentation um it was just literally
an Excel spreadsheet totally fine so you
have it obviously it kind of keeps going
further there's more columns than just
three i think there's about 50 in this
so you have column name associates like
okay I can see these rows these
individual valleys are going to be what
I'm going to see as Petters and the CSV
has the corresponding survey question in
this case it was a web survey so just
having the plain text of what was
prompted to the user or to the
participant who is responding that's
just enough information for me and then
it has the code values and that's
actually packed with a lot of
information I know that one when I see
one in that cell I can unpack that value
too I'm a US citizen or permanent
resident so I can see all of the options
that were that were given to the
participants and I know how they line up
now I don't see the descriptive
statistics in here but like honestly
that's an Excel problem and that's just
fun so in this case if I want to process
this data this can also be dumped out
into a CSV so that's really machine
readable and portable as well and very
preserva below ver time and so I can
then go through and take all of those
columns of information
and plug in these actual text values to
replace the numerical values and so if
I'm dealing with a small and data set
it's actually totally fine to just flip
back and forth between the the data and
the documentation to understand what's
going on but if you're talking like
something icpsr has huge data sets that
in fact have I got a thousand columns
because its longitudinal data and it's a
three hour interview on health behaviors
of the participant like that's pretty
awful too like when you at every answer
is coded numerically and that we pretty
awful in my analysis to try to
constantly flip back to the giant PDF of
checks values but having a
machine-readable makes it possible for
my system and I can you know taken away
from all all nice proprietary software
to make this pretty I can smash it in
Python together to get what I need out
of it and then of course sometimes
there's nothing and you're left looking
at that value of one two and three and
it should be a binary value and you're
wondering I was 3 b.b it was missing
maybe it wasn't I don't know and of
course if that binary value well
according to them you could see the the
paper survey and you know that they were
offered a binary male and female ah but
you don't and you're seeing one and two
and the answers and you're like which
one was one in which one was too and I
can't actually do anything with this
question because I have no idea how
things line up and I can't consequently
make any make any decisions trying to
read the mind of this depositor so now
that we've kind of taken a little brief
tour of tabular data documentation what
are the core elements that we just saw
there so we have little bit of data
profiling you can actually use it for
some data cleaning as well to make sure
the like you're like I remember that
that person had this weird edge case and
I'm not seeing it show up in there and
then you can go back and reiterate over
things and then you also have a little
bit of human narrative in the place in
places you have to explain like how I
had this question was asked and did it
change over time so when we have this
spectrum here of
perfect glorious icps are like gold
standard documentation and something but
informative and then the sad face of
nothing nothing I can do with this data
it's easier to improve something to
clean take it closer to perfection than
it is to start with something from
nothing like you know amber like it's
easier to edit your colleagues paper
than it is to start with a blank word
doc and make something glorious from
that so with that in mind I present
autodoc ish under the themes and purpose
in life automate what you can focus on
the elements that only you it's a human
individual being can answer and then
move on with your life like go do your
science go be us and go get those grants
get those publications ah so when we
expand this out so automate what you can
um we can look at data dictionaries
report the headers of a file i can do
that code books report the unique values
we just saw counter over there i can do
that too and set as well ah and
descriptive statistics or of course
statistics and these are all things that
a computer can do so what's left for the
humans we can provide context we can
describe the methods and you can do so
and pesky format of human sentences so
let's take a look so say you have a CSV
or you can provide the tool with the
source and that can be either a file or
a folder this currently only works with
CSVs but the low-hanging easy fruit
that's super common ah you tell it where
where to put the output so an output
folder name and then you can pry it
provide it with a single missing code so
and I'm really on this the this is
intentionally not like an alias name
think it's intentionally you are calling
this script file because it needs to be
customized it can be used kind of out of
the box but I'm expecting people to
customize it so you're going to have
probably one version for each data set
so in the output folder it's going to
provide like wine and profile data file
for every originating data file so if
you point it toward the single CSV
you're going to get a single data
profile if you point it to a folder with
thousand CSVs you're going to
thousand data profiles and then it'll
also at the very end put in a JSON file
containing all of that information that
you can take and do whatever you want
with it so this is an example of single
file usage so I pointed to vagrants I
CSV this is real data the citations
below I'm telling it throw throw all the
stuff into the vagrants folder and the
missing value i happen to know cuz no
this data is bracket missing I just is
giving you some confirmation language of
like making the thing for the file name
uh hey this folder already existing and
over at the profile information and then
confirming at the end that everything's
been written out so for folder usage
pretty much the same I'm pointing it at
a folder of fake data put the profiles
and fakes and giving it an empty string
um it'll actually presume an empty
string is the missing value if you don't
provide one so what are these data
profile files actually look like it is
really hard to make a giant txt file
look pretty on a screen so it's kind of
broken up into chunks that I'm going to
talk about so for file level information
this is an example data file of what it
was used on this is just like completely
random data that I generated um it's all
like integer random integers and then
like random text headers so it starts
off with data profile for and then it
puts whatever source um a relational
link you put in so if you put in the
relational path it'll put that in if you
put the full path it'll also put that in
and then the file name itself and then
generated on and the full time stamp
because why not put the whole thing in
when you get the whole thing this is the
data was created and then gives you a
little bit of the shape so in this case
it has ten columns and 108 rose and then
it's just confirming the fact that this
you told me that this had an empty
string for the missing values and of
course it's very hard to print an empty
string so in this case it actually just
reports those words so moving down and
underneath that file information at the
top then iterates through all of the
columns giving you so the column name to
start with and then kind of align and
then in this case it's actually printed
out for just plain text questions you
can customize
questions you can remove them you can
change them you can do whatever you want
with them these are sort of prompts for
you to start filling out your data
documentation as you're going through
and reading this file ah beneath that
again this is numerical example of
numerical data so it has a little bit of
descriptive descriptive statistics as
much as you can kind of do and a I'll
take everything kind of why so saying a
hundred percent of the values were found
to be digits zero percent were found to
be missing on the lowest digits found
one um I found more than 10 unique
values and this is a value that you can
adjust a threshold for I actually found
103 unique values within this thing with
the highest digit being 996 so moving on
to a more textual data this is actually
inside that vagrants file um so given a
file of text values again starts with a
column name so in this case it said
literally just gender of lead vagrant
and then a line has the same questions
to fill out and you can he's kind of
transcription data so you can add a
different question more related to that
or who did the transcription for this
column um saying zero percent were digit
zero percent were missing his Susan
Berman I can't keep a minimun digit
because there's no digits in this case
it's on three unique values and it's
reporting those below into this would be
a place that you could go in and
actually add in to like one male and two
female three boys refuse whatever if you
had something like that so scriptures
and then so this is a peek into the JSON
file so um you've got it iterating
through all of the file names in here
each file name contains information on
the columns and then the descriptive
statistics for each of those columns it
has some information I just the basic
shape and information about the CSV
itself and then some more file
information or file metadata including
the last date of access total size and
then just repeating the file name um and
then it repeats through that over and
over so looking inside the code a little
bit ah so this is just obviously just a
small snippet of inside the code but
basically for each file if it ends of
the CSV
get some information on it organize that
into and write out the profile so
organized that information into a giant
dictionary and then punt that out into a
markdown file and that's it like that's
all it's going through and so it's
calling these custom functions for
getting static at the headers and then
review a CSV because this is written
with the framework of bring your own
profiling functions you know your data
the best I shouldn't necessarily invest
my time and coming up with like really
bespoke tests when you're going to be
the one who knows it the best you're
going to have your own specific things
that you want to test for and that you
want to actually report back so you can
plug and chug your own files and your
own profiling function so if you want a
very specific kind of statistics on this
is also valid Python 3 catch uh-huh
whatever you want to do to this poor
little file you just write those
individual functions acting on the
individual column values you put in like
your conditional checks to figure out
like is this a column that should be
texting Exxon or is this one that should
be testing why on and you add those in
and um here and then with whatever
variable names you want kind of assemble
that into the dictionary and kind of
munch out a little bit and then it all
just gets printed up so people is not
required to use this package everything
is written into the standard Python 2.7
library and I do this because not only
am i coming from the digital
preservation perspective of I want
people to be able to use this thing in
like if you've produced stuff or if you
write a script on notice lee for this
kind of tool but like if you used you
write a script for your analysis and
your publishing that with your paper
like people need to know how to use it
in 10 years in 20 years also i teach
python and so when people get told hey
you just pick install this whatever
thing to make the thing that's necessary
for your thing to work when that doesn't
work they come to me and i'm the one who
has to get them installed with anaconda
installed with pip installed with python
also teaching them the command line and
terminal and
ash in the process and then putting it
all together into making it work or I
can just have someone with a straight
out of the box macbook run this Python
script also there's some really we saw
some amazing built-in tools and there's
you know just before this which is like
a awesome timing ah so it's really
important to me that anyone who's at
least kind of comfortable with running
some stuff in terminal be able to do
this because frankly I don't want to I'm
tired of trying to get people set up a
pip it's my job but it's important to do
that but it gets it's really hard when
you're in the consultation ah and
someone's like how do i run the thing
and then what's terminal and anyhow so i
encourage people to start thinking about
if you can write tools with less
external dependencies sometimes you
can't and that's totally fine but this
things to think about there's a lot of
stuff in a standard library so future
directions um this is just a proof of
concept I in the sense that it's easier
to harvest not with something than
nothing um if you want to take this and
you can add in your own profile
functions great if you could inspire it
but its general idea you can write
something to kind of automate your data
documentation on your regular like
quarterly data reports that come in or
data files that come in awesome um it
only works for CSVs because they're
common and easy and I do want to put in
more features to kind of try to
auto-detect the data types and optimize
some of the profiling functions from
that things I'd like to add is turning
this into a web tool that kind of
prompts people to go through Oh on our
website and like through every question
Phil things out and actually tell you
what it is and then it can better
optimize the profiling functions um
prettier outputs how am i doing on time
ok um so I can show you kind of how it
works a little bit on good ol iris data
yes you see I run the background
you're at it readable so this folder we
have a copy of the data profile py and
IRS so did a profile then you say iris
dot CSV and then there's not really any
missing value so I can actually just
admit that did I break it I broke it
last night I think I was trying to fix
things um what oh I didn't give it an
output to iris there we go kind of sick
of iris dated this fine i kind of have
like PTSD with flower data now after
lots of machine learning tutorials um
yeah so it's just going through all the
stuff and now and I look in here so i
have um going to stupid iris I see my
data profile so here we go so we have at
the start on this is generated today um
five columns hundred and fifty rose we
have supper length and some basic
information it goes from five to seven
thirty five unique values were found um
and then you have this is the more
interesting categorical data as far as
the unique values for the tosa
versicolor and virginica virginica uh
yeah so that's what it does take it
throw it away make your own thing
whatever you stuff CC BY so I'm github
all usual stuff so any questions
if it was so mangled that the CSV module
can't read it then it would throw an
error um but if the CSV module can read
it and it's reasonably square like it
probably would be fine things would look
funny um yeah yeah this might help like
if it was reasonably unmingled enough
for CSU to read it he would probably see
it like for example if if i erase data
got messed up like it was missing a Cell
all of a sudden you wouldn't see you
like you know petal width is supposed to
be a hundred percent digit then all of a
sudden it's like ninety-nine percent
digit and you say it has like numerical
and then like you see it's the
versicolor is one of the unique values
and there you know that something got
shifted and something's funky so this is
okay so looking yeah yeah so this might
be able to help you and you might be
able to um so you can also look at the
shape information as well if you're that
might be a feature to add as well to
kind of put a warning of like this isn't
like there's not the same number of
columns for each row but this could be
i've used this for work as well because
i'm getting data sets of all different
places coming in and it's a good way to
just do a really quick data profile
because when you kind of you expect
something to be one hundred percent
digits or at least why is something
ninety-nine percent digit I don't not
expecting text value
is in this or all the sudden you see
like negative values when you know they
should all be positive integers um so
yeah take it for a test um you can fork
it make it your own make it something
that might be useful for you um this is
kind of is the original part of this was
a class project for daily cleaning glass
and then I just kind of kept going with
it actually happens to be useful for my
job as well so if you if this framework
can be made useful in your own way you
totally do that that is written in my
spare time yeah hmm back oh yeah so it
is actually not uh autodoc ish because
it didn't have a cute name until I was
writing the talk proposal for this
otherwise I was gonna have a calf area
academic talk title like towards
automatic data documentation but auto da
key I think he's a little bit more fun
so our auto doc ish so so okay um I'm
around it's on it's around you've got
the internet now at least so all right
thanks